so we've covered the first three
uh joe skis the next one is ski
get engage it's a
a ski and then a low
the side of the knee and the intention
is to
break the knee
remember all the points so far
two fingers grip firm
firm but not not too tight
don't come round don't look down
this is a very difficult one to
understand because the pros and cons
the first part you should know if you've
done the
shokuzuki correct
it draws back at the same time you draw
back
i open my front foot some teachers don't
i can only be me this is what i've found
why do i open my front foot
why do i have it like this
fly's attacking me
when i come forward now to break the
knee
the back foot what was the front foot
can stay there
from here if i leave it
here close what i call closed
at the end of this
it will twist
and since i was aged in my early 30s
i've had osteoarthritis in the knees
and i've found that it applies pressure
on the knees well that can't be good for
your well-being can it
so by having a a weakness in my knees at
an early age
it's it pointed out to me that um
doing it my way it doesn't destroy my
knees so my knees have kept pretty much
intact
the last 40 years
if it wants to slide it can slide it can
move
but you don't want that twist because
the twist is coming from the upper body
going
all the way through the leg and twisting
the knee
and that foot and you're losing power
then
if the foot that then
and this this this powerful strike from
the hips
is being lost through that through that
twist
so
takes a lot of power it's going to take
a lot of power to break somebody's knee
from the side
so the pros and cons you're here
you just pull it back and go back then
it's like now you've got to start a
second move up
plus this twist you're going to lose
you're going to lose
mass so that means you're going to lose
power
if you watch slowly my hips there's
always some movement in the body
so i don't make it a two stage this is a
two stage
now i've gotta start it again
and it has to be one stage
ski get engaged
[Music]
so when i'm going back by opening the
foot it's actually
not on the foot but it's turning the hip
we would start in this position in the
ready command position
can you see the hips moving
so by their hips while ending up and
finding power
it's going to give that crack in the
in the jar isn't it so you can start
in both modes
this mode
or the ready camera
so we've done the three thrusting
movements
and now these are the two where we
thrust
higher we thrust to the abdomen
again when practice on your own aim for
your own parts of your body
lower stomach high
knee knee height not too
low your knee height
and so you've got principle of targets
principal targets that you've
you've aimed for if you you have a
mirror
or window you can watch yourself really
clearly
it's the best thing for training
and then you can see where your knees in
the mirror or window
so it's a higher ski
right to the way
make
skate
[Music]
okay there's always more uh the one of
the biggest things
that i want to tell you on all of those
four so far
should have said at the beginning but
try to check
out if you're tense are you trying too
hard
it's good to try but if you're tense
then try to
acknowledge that and say to yourself
i've got to
not get so tense
so this is a sequence now you can put
together don't make it a carter
but a nice tidy sequence
just check save your tents or if you can
chill out a little
bit
neat
stop